true let's messed up say hello and
welcome to this video instead a good
screen now that all it's good yeah
screwed up the screens a mouse and yeah
let's play maradona i am from Iceland
here's our Kings Indian guide I think
trying the Petrosian system might be to
the seven letters this is the old line
85 is more common nowadays but
advantages I don't really know any
details here film n° lately there should
be three shouldn't be all that bad night
h5 hmm ok he wants to do this night term
g7 Bishop to e7 maneuver possible maybe
I can play this and try for a quick h5
okay if I go like 95 to go go to g7 that
doesn't do anything at all night h 2 97
h 5 this is possible all this yeah let's
do it so I can take on age 6 I think
taking looks like farm blog more logical
yeah and now he does not um Tretton f4
directly maybe he takes and plays night
at five something like that however
after taking I have G for the other
thing in this position is he might play
F for nobody this I don't believe in all
that much so let's see yeah that was it
was clear but I have a gingy file opened
and I don't quite believe that this is
not having any effect here I know 95 who
might happen but we will see
yeah i would expect him to take this one
oh this is 1 i'm taking definitely
getting a pawn on e5 is much better than
having in having to face the peas on e5
so this is basically a no-brainer oops
okay yeah man we can't go at three but
now it's just a nice position for widen
its not straining interesting so
potentially just did at Queen h2 okay
I'm turtling stuff Queen h8 hook h7 is a
threat
we never ate one what now that doesn't
even look all that decisive I should try
to get the night to d3 this what would
end it as I'm attacking me five and this
is a pawn that cannot be covered
naturally I play king be one to play 92
c 1 d 3 and that should be the end of it
another combined entry of the Queen and
[Music]
interesting yeah I think I just take and
complete this night maneuvers that I
mentioned
now I entering with the Queen and at the
same time attacking you five should be
very problematic for black my night h5 i
can probably take 36 I mean to be honest
I don't know where I which I would just
do it take the six th five and that
night when you wear a bit slow but I
think it's a factor also good look look
g5 lined up yeah I can take you five now
and I probably should f4 is hanging as
well yeah clean trait I don't know it
looks better to keep the Queen's Own
okay maybe to c3 was better well it
steps let's just check for a moment
Queen highly 445 probably ah I've got
look 32 is that this is annoying check
check
and the bickering is weak it's going to
be a problem
Queen a five-year mother was an issue we
just cleaned III coming up III was very
cautious move I don't know if that was
necessary strictly speaking probably not
now if she doubled up here I just take
physics I don't know that should should
crash through so here does not allow it
on what now maybe I quinta to shoot it's
got Quincy to now that doesn't
necessarily need to be a problem I don't
know let us what the step threaten if I
do this 93 he just takes them I have no
tiny I'm a bloody [ __ ] why am I taking
so much time and now he's taking lots of
time
hi you can slower than i was at one time
we had added and it's just freezing that
position is completely winning provide
I'm pretty certain that I was just just
freezing yeah i think that opening
result was was pretty miserable for
black yeah this is a funny idea which I
have my doubts I mean why does opening
up the H Valley and that cannot be saved
for black the engine does not want to
play at 5pm and two after a five already
yeah basically says white wins which is
a bit strong but yeah green stood to i
think is good because whenever he does
he takes here i was thinking gee form
and the engine just wants to take or
play castle I thought about this move
just stopping any night f5 which is also
a big advantage okay night late effort
and this also must be better for for
white absolutely no doubt just a matter
how much it is his king is just
permanently unsaved yet here should be
seven justice yeah it must be an
advantage this king is unsafe this pawn
as weak it's pretty awful these six we
are not surprised that there was
something more powerful available but
I'm kind of happy with this looks
completely overwhelming Queen h7 already
was stronger yeah I like this clever
idea here with the night maneuver with
que creen h7 was very straightforward
yeah that wasn't so convincing as I
expected I kind of expected that
that the engine didn't like this
decision yeah might see one d3s engine
you know I wasn't I wasn't really
thinking clearly and 93 I can still just
take so I could do this envisioned
maneuver and I mean like here this this
now I have this idea also oops sorry is
this idea and so let that wasn't model
great still better but it's not not to
decisive check well okay now here you
can easily screw things up it's just
murky a look takes each one lyst AA Wow
oorah gamma night see one was still
winning yeah I could have taken here
because yeah this is not ending well the
create for was winning and now I was
freezing somehow and all of a sudden
notice how here how little time i
actually have 23 in the position is
clearly better or winning or whatever
but the time at the end who are on with
the tip there is scary ok guys thanks
for watching